[Musica]
sto gioco è fatto troppo bene io il
porto giochi di merda in genere cambiamo
video bella tutti ragazzi meno che vi
sono io siamo su io sono felice va beh
questo non si era capito insomma
sull'attacco dei giganti due hanno fatto
il 2 del videogioco che hanno detto che
20 volte più veloce il primo addirittura
ed è in italiano credo che piaccia anche
a mia nonna l'attacco dei giganti non
credo ci siano persone che madonna le
cinematiche sono fatela dio è fatto
meglio dell'anime valko è possibile
madonna
urca vaccamorta questa è la bellissima
mi aspettavo ma qui e rennes
no non era a e addio annie ricco bottino
miracco è passato non so che è passato
un sacco di tempo da quando vi sposate
quelli madonna bank ha fatto bene a
questo proprio la seconda parte va il
parto parto non sono morti tutti come
beh mica tanto ciao frate oddio armin
fatto bello stop me la sexy ma spyda di
90 inizia la china di pechino soci a
cuore tenero negata nocesi musicisti by
parto parto anche io posso
in tutto il suo tempo che si sta
sostenuto quella arrivata fin lì solo ai
un aspetto aspetta come si fa in borsa
capace momenti con vaste usa con te e
vabbè non capisco questa mini sta
dicendo ma va bene perché meno dai me la
cavo eccola allora ragazzi faccio una
premessa la faccio dopo perché stanno
succedendo tante cose ma è uguale
all'anima e ci hanno fatto scene
identiche tissimo button che botta forte
e mi sa che mi sa che l'abbiamo persa
vai partiamo ragazzi devo far vista
premessa non mi ricordo i nomi dei
personaggi perché passato tipo un anno
da quando ho visto la seconda parte
l'attacco di giganti quindi lei si
chiama annie ha un attimo al casinò come
faccia attaccarla aiuto scassati dove
l'attacco non sono capaci animale è il
momento di abbatterla e occhio che
questa s'arrampica occhio ma qua non è
quando crolla il muro non lo so non
ricordo
questo attacco me si attacca o che tasto
attacco ma se non me lo dici con che
testo attacco ma che se non me lo dici
che ne so io allora mi capita a col
tasto destro ok è perfetto dovevo
avergli fatto malissimo
se ti sei cagato addosso è che ho fatto
male
porca vacca
[Musica]
eccolo eccolo eccolo incazzato number
one
la donna che cartone in bocca
mi sa che le hai fatto male credo quando
riesce a prendere sei in matematica sono
cc nuovo umori da stop
la mado quanto fatto bene sia in sarete
i tanti
[Musica]
chiusi in dotano
minchia manco rigore di cristiano
ronaldo
ehi
[Musica]
ha fatto il buco aperto lungo nel muro
parla
ma sono io in prima persona che sto
scappando ma no dai che figata
questi sono i miei genitori
[Musica]
non è vero
no non è vero
no non ne voleva andare
c'è già all'inizio di l'attacco dei
giganti è bruttissimo nel senso che è
troppo triste
adesso ci hanno fatto vedere un'altra
parte che ancora più triste che non
c'era nell'anime questo bambino è parso
i genitori così bene il bambino dovrei
essere io tra l'altro
ma dai ma che non sa io invece sono stop
bambino da parte no bellissimo quindi è
persona questo bambino che ha perso i
genitori è l'attacco iniziale fatto
veramente ma devo farvi personaggio ma
dai
ci vediamo qua quando l'ho finito perché
se non ci mettiamo una vita vabbè ci ho
provato nei limiti del possibile
facciamo così alla carlo e il nome carlo
armando in che modo ti serve il mio nome
cosa te ne fai armando un altro nome
patetico davano al nulla ma io sono
l'unico vestito di blu tra tutti horeca
racco n'è andato cinque anni dopo 5
entra nei new york song ei mutui muro
stare pure cana
mamma mia non me l'aspettavo te lo giuro
incredibile
ricorre per il real madrid
asca vacca chiamare anch'io sono volato
burqa walter dovrai frate ormai a ma
quando dovrebbe cercare di fargli il
culetto eren in teoria
[Musica]
cusin goffo i tipi
ce la facciamo ce la facciamo mai forza
fammi vedere che cosa ha imparato tanto
vieni non so come è fatto un gigante
l'ho visto miliardo rivolto alla
tecnologia attiva
allora capiamo il collo destro fi
[Musica]
madonna ha chiesti a è andato mi sa che
è morto eliminato il gigante grande
grazie se quello del gigante grande
questo quale che cos'è spiega chissà che
non dovevo stare proprio in quel punto
mentre stava sferrando il calcio forse
non è il massimo della protezione
la donna che botta forte
ecco sono ri morto adesso finito io
niente qua davanti mi sono fatto nulla a
posto non dimenticare di curarsi le
ferite come come le cure le ferite
spiegano all right perfetto bevuto un po
di succo d'ananas tutto a posto dai
ragazzi allora questa parte era una
parte che c'era anche nel primo se vi
ricordate voce fatto un viso sono su
questa parte qui però qua e fa
innanzitutto è fatta da dio è molto
meglio dell'altra ok la pighin dovuta ma
questo è il gigante grande perché si
chiude come com'è il gigante piccolo
spiegami di più felici che anche
lanciato all'interno vice era il tuo
ammazza quello grosso e miami è morto
non è morto madonna che brutto no l'ho
mancato sono scemo da mancato
soprattutto stupido o chiare se lo
prendo questa era gigante grande questo
gigante nano finalmente e pisa rispetta
è andato giù subito questa veramente
troppo subito
madonna che testata mazza mangili al
mcdonald è questo occorre un po e un po
scemo però si può far fuori che aspetta
vedo attaccano mamma mia il modo in cui
ti muovi è fantastica
e merito di just dance zio studio mi
sento tutta caratteri d'oro ma cosa sta
combattendo che è fermo l'altro bastava
lì a girargli intorno non va bene
[Musica]
si sfoga takase inca chiedo io so anche
chi è però non posso spoiler arvelo
problema batta adesso ci sono tutti gli
altri a far fuori che hanno invaso tutta
quanta la zona di non rilasci loro
facendo non stai facendo zio spiega
miceli attacco l'addome prende un
materiale 18 al braccio grazie ottenuto
una pietra preziosa ce l'aveva dentro il
gomito st pietra al governo
spesso la fate a farlo fuori lega dai lo
fa tutto io
madonna meno male che esiste una
minimappa se non mi perderei ogni 5
secondi per ora mi spaventa e questo
altro ciao fratello dove sei non ti vedo
ecco lo sta facendo
poiché tutto scemo questo non sta bene
capendo cosa sta facendo questo prova
morto ciò fatto stavolta fare amicizia
avvicinati ai mire premi eti sembra il
momento di fare amicizia questo amicizia
la fai la sera dietro un boccale di
birra non qua doveva quello tutela ma
dove vai
c'è un muro grosso come tua madre ma lo
stesso cosa ho visto
oddio paga fatelo fuori vi prego sto
morendo
va bene un carraia devo fare attenzione
a giocare a questo gioco senza
spoilerarvi le cose perché il 4
ci vuole un po di musica qua
[Musica]
stavo dicendo devo fare attenzione a
giocarci senza spoilerarvi l'anime
perché magari qualcuno di voi non l'ha
visto quindi non posso dire cose che so
barca di la collottola bravo così
marianella cervicale può accompagnare
solo
ieri qualche dobbiamo fare amicizia in
questo momento ce l'hai le carte imier
che parte il bryston e selvaggio eccoti
qui zia
ciao facciamo amicizia nelle giocate a
carte o niente abbiamo fatto amicizia
sono entrati 20 giganti chiaro ma sto
facendo quei due madonne e hinson
infattibili c'è pure cavuoto grosso non
me lo aspettavo così grosso serio tirali
lo scià pool bene così ora se riuscissi
a rifare questa cosa perche e andata
come da una ragazza fare stragi bene
guarda come va armando sa bene come
balla nando trovato il cadetto attaccato
del gigante grande staccargli la mano le
partite la mano l'hai lasciato andare
ora cavalca ti aiuto un attimo
ragazzi ci sono dei problemi qui burqa
questo potrebbe essere un problema
[Musica]
e andato arrivato o poi ce l'abbiamo
fatta ragazzi
è un braccio e partito se riusciste a
farlo fuori anzi forse le gambe alle
gambe
raga questo potrebbe essere un problema
cosa è successo e cosa ha visto cosa è
successo vuol chiamare cosa fa è scemo
scemo e scemo fortissimo ma questo è
bruciato
ahi ahi ahi a questo fa male non mi ha
preso grazie a dio non mi a target dato
pro l'ha fatto malissimo e in faccia non
si fa niente se voleva uccidermi ma non
è miseramente fallito nel suo intento è
se riuscissi porca vacca farlo fuori
andato bene ci è voluto un botto per far
fuori scavalca ha fatto dai ragazzi
basta adesso continueremo sicuramente
nel prossimo episodio perché ci sono
milioni di cosa da fare in questo nuovo
gioco farò altri episodi più avanti
comunque fatemi sapere se il gioco vi
piace a me è piaciuto un botto fino alla
cia veramente figo i ragazzi spero vi
sia piaciuto come si vocifera mente
milan capolista di amicizia direi che ci
siamo ma possibile da ragazzo
[Musica]